mindfulness is not a concept it's a
practice you have to actually exercise a
certain kind of muscle our repeated
experiences shape our brain you can't be
in the moment if you can't concentrate
the ability to be present
stems from being able to be concentrated
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
develop some mindfulness habits
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one rest in awareness with john
kabat-zinn is mindfulness science is it
art is it spiritual it's
it's a gateway
into
the full dimensionality of being human
oh and being alive i love that it's a
gateway into the full dimensionality of
being human and without it you're just
missing out
well
you're missing a lot uh you know if if
you miss the look in your child's eye
one day you've missed it uh if you've
missed the look in your lover's eyes the
next day you've missed that if you miss
the beauty of sitting under trees well
you've missed that if you sum that over
uh many moments many years you may wind
up missing
the most beautiful aspects of your own
life who are you going to blame for that
i was too busy well who who who is too
busy who tells oneself i don't have any
time
when all you've got is time all you've
got is this moment waking up of course
is what it's all about i mean it's about
being awake right yeah
but there's waking up and then there's
waking up so you can wake up and like
drag yourself around so brushing your
teeth meditation being in the bathroom
it's all like part of it but then i go
downstairs i get on my yoga mat and i
have a routine that i've developed over
the past 50 years that's just like what
i like to do
and i do that mindfully so it's mindful
yoga and then
out of that at when the time is right
maybe it's an hour maybe it's 40 minutes
or whatever it is then i i drop into
sitting and i usually sit cross-legged
on the floor but you can sit in a chair
and i just kind of drop into the body
body is like a really important part of
this can we live inside the body because
most of the time we don't
and then can we rest in awareness just
rest
underline rest in wakefulness in
awareness in mindfulness in heartfulness
and that's the practice now there are a
lot of different ways to do it there are
a lot of different details but the most
important thing i think for your viewers
is
drop in
drop in on yourself
and rest
for a stretch of time and then as you go
about your daily life mindfulness in
everyday life check in
it's just like that
once an hour once once a minute check in
once a day it's like you decide but at a
certain point it's going to wind up
teaching you you know what we like to
say i'm i meditate you know here's
another one like i'm breathing i'm
meditating
uh or you'll say i'm doing the practice
that's the way meditators talk they say
i'm doing my practice
after a while it doesn't feel that way
anymore it feels more like the practice
is doing me
i am learning so much it's like the
world
is teaching me everything i need to know
if i only
get quiet and drop in and attend
mindfulness is all about being
and the cliche goes we're called human
beings but we actually have lost touch
with that
element of life that's what we were
doing sitting around fires as hunted
together
but now it's gotten so much more complex
what mindfulness is saying is find your
own way listen to your own heart listen
to your own use the word longing longing
listen to your own yearning because what
we're really trying to do is
live our life as if it really mattered
because it does it does and i like to
say
more than you think
and then
more than you can think i like to say to
people
okay here's a little homework for you
after we've talked about mindfulness and
and it's it's very important to keep in
mind that mindfulness is not a concept
it's a practice you have to actually
exercise a certain kind of muscle so i
say here is a little mindfulness
homework for you the next time you're in
the shower
check and see if you're in the shower
because you may not be in the shower you
or you may have your whole monday
morning nine o'clock meeting in the
shower with you
but you're not actually there under the
water feeling the water on your skin
you're off in the future or off in the
past so that's exercising the muscle the
more you do that the more you realize
when i'm in the shower i'm in the shower
when i'm brushing my teeth i'm brushing
my teeth when i'm saying goodbye to my
family i'm saying goodbye to my family
it only takes a fraction of a second
longer to do it with awareness okay so
everybody who's watching this right now
the next time you get in the shower
you're going to think am i in the shower
or are you in the meeting or you already
check on the freeway check and as soon
as you check your back
and you you have you have something you
can do about it if you are obsessed with
some kind of thing worried about how
things gonna go that day or whatever
that's all fine your awareness is big
enough to hold it all it's not like now
you have to suppress all that thinking
or the meeting in the shower the knowing
it is good enough that knowing is what
we call awareness and then
it's laughable so you'll feel better
when we get quiet
when we get still when we rest you could
say an awareness
our natural impulse to see connections
that we didn't see the moment before
uh is unimpeded and we can actually make
these connections and realize them in
ways that we might not have been able to
do the moment before the easiest thing
for people to think
about mindfulness is that
it equals awareness
you and i sitting here having a
conversation you know the thought might
cross one of our minds well when are we
going to get down to meditating the fact
is we are mindfulness is is a particular
way of being in relationship to your
life
and the place to start of course is the
fact that we're only live
in this moment
the future hasn't happened yet the past
is memory and is over
but if you start to pay attention to
where your mind is most of the time it's
not in the present moment it's off
someplace else obsessing about
the past or planning or worrying about
the future so what mindfulness is is a
particular way of paying attention
and the awareness that arises from
paying attention in that way habit
number two allow time to decompress with
giselle bungen you can make decisions
from a place of really instead of like
you know rush decisions and like i have
to make this decision and you you're not
very clear about it when you can take a
step back and become the observer
you make decisions with a different
level of awareness with a different
clarity and therefore
better decisions i think in the very
beginning when i was going through my
severe anxiety and panic attacks um i
actually
went into like you know i don't know if
you guys ever heard about vipassana
which is like a 10-day like intense
meditation um
i actually do like seven days and go in
silence and just meditate for seven days
and with that a lot of stuff comes up
obviously when you're not talking you
realize how much the monkey mind is
trying to take control because that's
the job of the mind right it's the kind
of he's like a friend told me this once
he says gisele the mind is an instrument
don't let it play you
so it's it's a really powerful thing to
remember to be just
just remember that you know that that is
that's the job of the mind is to hold on
to things and to to kind of attach to
things and it's your job to say i choose
this thought and i don't choose that and
i you know because whatever you give
energy to is what grows i actually have
a chapter in my book that he talks about
that is like
you know where your energy goes is what
grows and it's like we have to choose
where we put our energy in because
that's where we're going to manifest so
it's it's
the the more
consciously and we can make those
choices and where we're letting our mind
go the better is going to be for us do
you find your meditation practice also
makes you more kind of outward focused
on the world
i think it just gives you a different
kind of awareness i think you see things
from a different place i think
everything slows down and you become
more
conscious of i think of everything
because when you meditate what you do is
like you become
you become silent and i think there's
especially in our society today
everything is happening so fast i mean i
remember when i was a kid you know there
was no cell phones like even when i
moved to japan i had to use my the
calling cars to call my mom and be like
you know you got one dollar left and i
you know i called my mom like once a
month from japan because there was no
you know 1994
you know 1995
and and i think you know someone calls
the house and you're like wait a minute
i'll get the message from my mom you
know i remember when the phones came out
and they had actually the message that
you can leave a message before that you
couldn't so you had like a notepad and a
pencil next to the phone to leave the
message and i think it was in a way so
great because you know
people could do their job and then could
go home and they would have
conversations with dinner table with
their family and they would if people
couldn't catch them at work they would
have to wait to the next day and now i
think with this kind of speed up process
where you're available 24 7
i think is is really creating a lot more
anxiety so i think even more so it's
important to have the moments if like
you said you know a few times a day i
don't think you need to go for like
seven you know every passenger or like
five days maybe sometimes you do if you
have a specific thing you're dealing
with but if it would be good if every
day you can check in you know if he's
two minutes in a car ride if it's five
minutes in the morning when you wake up
if it's before you go to bed if it's
before an important meeting just to
take a moment you know go go into going
go anywhere take you know focus on your
breath
deep breathing and just allow yourself
to
you know to kind of decompress i think
it's essential to be able to deal with
the amount of pressure we have in our
society today i mean i don't know how
else i mean i couldn't do it without it
when i see myself getting like kind of
like
ants in my pants and i feel like a
little bit like agitated and i can't
really
i'm like you know this is a good moment
for me to take a you know five minutes
and just go in word and i come out of it
just
i don't know if it's because i i allow
myself to breathe deeply and i and i can
really feel
myself getting back into my body because
i think a lot of times when the anxiety
and all those things comes like if you
notice you're not breathing
you're outside of your body everything
becomes very hectic and then if you can
just center yourself just take that
moment is a gift
that costs nothing you know is a gift is
the biggest gift i think you know that
you can just all it takes is the
awareness to say you know this is the mo
this is
i'm going to take this five minutes or
two minutes or however long i have right
now to just sit in silence and
and breathe habit number three take a
step back with jay shetty i usually like
to compare mindfulness to a remote
control
imagine you could press pause on a
thought
imagine you could use that time to just
reflect
take a step back
observe
imagine you could fast forward to
something in the past learn from it
straight away
and then press play again when you felt
comfortable does that sound like a good
idea would that feel good
mindfulness really allows you to find
that clarity
space
time
so that you can actually navigate your
mind
and not just be led by it
to wherever it may flow we spend so much
of our life lost in the maze
and lost in the details that we often
don't be able to get that bird's eye
view so we've just shown how actually
one of the biggest things the greatest
things about mindfulness is just that
slight
three steps backwards so that we can
look at our challenges look at our
situations when we need to with a bit
more space
one of the second things i hear often is
that mindfulness is for those who are
stressed or meditation is for those who
are struggling with mental health the
incredible thing is harvard stanford you
name it they've done incredible
scientific studies around how
mindfulness
actually helps people become more
focused become more creative
and be able to apply their attention
anywhere and everywhere they like
and one of my favorite things about that
is i often say that silicon valley has
done more for mindfulness than the monks
have because silicon valley have been
such great proponents of mindfulness and
their practice of it with their
employees who have to be creative who
have to be inventing the next steps
that mindfulness actually allows us to
do that
everyone i have been reading a bit from
my friend's book evan carmichael built
to serve and i wanted to share this with
you so
according to a study by carnegie mellon
university people with supportive
spouses are more likely to give
themselves the chance to succeed they
studied 163 married couples and found
that people with supportive spouses were
more likely to take on potentially
rewarding challenges those who accepted
challenges experienced more personal
growth happiness and psychological
well-being now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was just starting out i
had never released a video i hadn't
created any content and she was such an
important part of feeling supported on
that journey so whether you're in a
relationship whether you're dating
whether you're married or even if you're
single being supported by friends and a
strong community is important build to
serve by evan carmichael great book on
how you can find your purpose and also
on reminding us that we can all make a
difference in the world thanks evan
habit number four reflect with dr
hansaji yogendra when you enter the yoga
institute that small little gate we have
written there please close the door
mindfulness is yoga
whatever you are doing see that your
mind is present there and you do
you see human mind is very intelligent
mind highly developed mind so that mind
is going anywhere and everywhere it
doesn't stay at one place that's the
whole problem with us
because we are highly developed by an
animal mind is simple
when an animal
is hungry animal goes in search for food
and mind doesn't go anywhere else
because it's hungry so the need is there
otherwise he will not survive mind is
focused on that totally focused
concentration is perfected animals
natural but human human needs are so
many
and their needs are so many and not that
need like animal birth or death type
if you can't eat food from you'll be
struggling
nothing like that in human life and so
mind goes anywhere and everywhere
usually what happens is when we suffer
thoroughly thoroughly well in life then
we think of changing
till then we have that laziness in us
let it be a cat difference does it make
that type of a personality yoga would
never accept
you would see to it that if you are
doing you do it very well under pain and
suffering there is some little
resolution in mind that now you will not
do this you will do this sometimes
person is talking talking and talks
something which is not so good
and then she realizes or he realizes
that i should not have spoken this
well so now you become mindful
is it required to speak then only open
your mouth otherwise don't open
this little thinking has to go deeper
into us
so this way we become little alert and
aware
mindfulness means awareness
so first of all form a habit that
whatever you are doing you see to it
that you your mind is there with you
when you are doing anything let it be
brushing your teeth or eating your food
or talking to each other or doing
anything or even resting sleeping your
mind should be there with you while
sleeping really present to the moment
yes
you have come to the point that you
learn to be in present moment and that
will help you
uh to do your job well so unless you are
mindful
you will not be able to do any work well
in life this habit where your body is
your mind should be
where your mind is your emotion should
be
where your emotions are your faith
should be
faith means confidence
willpower that should be then you do
your work
so
either you are doing work mechanically
without mind
or mind is there but emotions are not
there you do it very in a dry way like
machine now everything should be present
body mind emotion and faith
all these four things together and you
are working
that is mindfulness
so we should form such habit
let's do few things but do it
systematically very well
so we have one technique in yoga we
always say that at night before going to
bed just reflect
how did you spend your day
you should know how did you spend your
day and what did you do so right from
till now earlier one hour before what
did you do still before what did you do
till your morning when you got up and
then you realize there are certain
things which you don't even remember
i know one boy he came to me he had
definitely he was wearing something else
in the morning he was wearing something
else but he's
telling me and said i don't know whether
i have taken bath or not mind is not
there only
while taking bath while eating food
while going here and there that has that
is the biggest problem now
now the mind has become so mechanical
with all these machines and gadgets in
our hand
that little
toy which we have always the computer
and the
phone mobile phone
that we are not using our mind
everything is used by the autopilot that
autopilot
that is very wrong
when it comes to self-development
see to it that you are not so much
dependent on anything
but
dependent on yourself so be very very
clear when mind is with you you will
never go to past
you will rather
remain in present from past you learn
history is for learning you the history
of anything you just learn from that
don't remain
in past remaining in past means you are
your progress is going down
as far as future is concerned don't
think about it
past will always bring tears in your
eyes
and future will always bring fear in
your
what will happen what will happen
remain in present that will bring
cheer
in your life
there are four things which you are
supposed to do in a day
one is doing your duty all your
responsibilities and duties you must do
second is earning money that is your
duty
third is rest recreation hobbies
equally important that you should do and
fourth is some selfless work
something for others
and so these are four types of work so
where your spiritual growth will occur
so these four types of things you should
do so become mindful have i done all
these four things no then plan your day
next day better and do it better so try
and live life like that and it would be
beautiful how about number five evolve
with sadhguru in a day from the moment i
leave the sleep time for you
that also needs to be considered but we
will leave that from the moment you come
awake till the moment you fall asleep
how many moments and how many actions
and how many thoughts and how many
emotions
or how much percentage of it
do you conduct consciously
this will determine the state of your
revolution right now
if you conduct it consciously you will
do it in a certain way
if you're going about compulsively
you will look like any other creature
yes
you look like just any other creature
not any different
once you do things compulsively
only when you conduct it consciously you
seem to be
on the peak of evolution on this planet
not otherwise
so you can gauge by yourself i don't
pass i don't want to pass a judgment on
anybody
from the moment you come awake till the
time you go asleep fall asleep
how much percentage of time are you
conducting your body your mind your
emotion your energy and your actions
consciously
if you are less than one percent you
know there's a lot of work to do
and i would
tell you
the if i have to speak frankly more than
ninety percent is less than one percent
less than well below one percent more
than ninety percent of the people
those ten percent who do little more
than one percent certainly they look
like such graceful beings
just from tomorrow morning
you want to do it from tomorrow morning
or now
from this moment till you fall asleep
just see
how much of you can you conduct
consciously
all aspects of you
your body your actions your mind your
thoughts your emotions your energies
everything
to what extent can you conduct it
consciously you see
if you conduct this consciously for five
minutes
by tomorrow morning people will bow down
to you
without knowing why they're doing
so that's evolution
and it's something you can do if you
just say it's me not something else
you'll evolve because once you become
human
you have enough awareness and
consciousness to evolve consciously when
you were a monkey you did not decide i
will become human being
nature
just pushed you on
but now you're conscious enough to
decide i want to evolve from where i am
to whatever is possible
just just try
just maintain five minutes manage your
life consciously today you will see
tomorrow morning how you will be
you will be shining believe me habit
number six cultivate a loving attitude
with dr ron siegel mindfulness is a
translation of a poly term and pali was
the vernacular language in which the
teachings of the historical buddha were
first written down
and the word in pali is sati
and it connotes awareness
attention and remembering and the
awareness and attention part are pretty
much the way we use them in english to
be aware and to pay attention but the
remembering is different it's not about
remembering what you had for breakfast
or for that matter even remembering
childhood trauma it's about remembering
to be aware and pay attention at each
moment of our day
now there's a um a scholar of the
ancient text named john dunn at emory
university
and he raised the following criticism he
said
you know if you could imagine a sniper
poised on top of a building getting
ready to take out an innocent victim
that sniper would be very aware
very attentive and every time his mind
wandered from the task at hand he'd be
zeroing right in on it and john said i
don't think that's exactly the attitude
you're trying to develop in yourselves
as a psychotherapist nor the attitude
you're trying to cultivate in your
patients or clients something's missing
here
and what's missing is a sense of
non-judgment acceptance kindness and
friendliness now there are some scholars
who say that's included in sati but the
important point is that this
non-judgment or acceptance is a skill
unto itself and which takes some work to
cultivate let me show you what i mean
join me in looking at this fellow
and just take in the picture of him
and see what emotion arises as you look
at him
and raise your hand of what you feel is
a sense of harsh and critical judgment
[Music]
we can talk afterwards if so but you
know most of us look at him and feel
something like oh
right okay now even if he pees and poops
at the wrong time in the wrong place
even if he doesn't listen to
instructions we can understand he's
young he's a puppy he needs training
right
now when you take out mindfulness
practices most of us one of the first
things we see is that our mind does
actually pee and poop at the wrong time
in the wrong place and it doesn't listen
to instructions at all that is quite
quite unruly and the same kind of loving
attitude that we would cultivate toward
that puppy that's what we're going to
try to cultivate toward whatever arises
in our consciousness including
depressive feelings anxious feelings
physical pain and the like there's a
well-known zen teaching story
about a
horrible sadistic general
who had come to town this was in
medieval japan
and they were
burning crops and burning buildings and
killing the able-bodied boys and men and
they were raping women it was horrible
and this general really wanted to
vanquish the town's folks and he caught
wind that they respected their zen
master
so he took his horse and he rode up the
hillside into the main hall of the zen
temple and they're sitting on the
meditation cushion as this little old
man the zen master
and the general takes his bloody sword
he holds it over the zen master he says
don't you realize i can run you through
the sword without blinking an eye and
little old man looks up and he says yes
and i sir can be run through with a
sword without blinking an eye
and it said that at that moment the
general becomes disoriented and leaves
town
now it's not always going to work as a
military intervention but it speaks to
how these practices develop our capacity
to be with discomfort and not to have to
escape it once we've practiced
mindfulness for a while and spent time
dropping out of the thought stream and
staying at the sensory level let's say
the anger comes up and all i experience
is the body tensing up heart rate
increasing respiration increasing blood
pressure well you don't feel blood
pressure but body temperature increasing
and perhaps the thought right coming in
passing like a cloud in the sky
perhaps the image of decapitating my
former friend dancing through the minds
of high but it's all seen as a kind of
impersonal process of mental contents
arising and passing and when we can
experience it that way
we get much less caught in it and it is
much easier to let it come and go habit
number seven feel passionate with
brendan burchard detachment from any
feeling emotion or even sometimes
expectation
to the day it's not feeling anything and
allowing yourself to feel things even
when they're good you know a lot of
people have done so much work in their
life to blot out negative emotion that
they're not letting in positive emotion
or so many people feel like they've been
failing so much in their lives they
don't have a connection to the things
when they do succeed so they're not
integrating success right they might
have a good thing a good series of
things happens to them but they don't
feel them they don't allow themselves to
take that success in that that win in it
and really internalize and say wow you
know i did that
and since that moment of satisfaction or
pride to doing something amazing they
never allow themselves any of the
positive emotions of life and they don't
allow those imposing emotions to stick
to settle in that's why one of the first
things that a psychologist will do in
working with a new patient is make sure
at the end of the day they start
journaling positive things that happen
throughout their day it's been
scientifically proven that you can
essentially just start a gratitude
journal and lift up your level of
happiness in life why because now you're
paying attention for the things that do
bring you positive emotion and happiness
in life you're recording them you're
writing them down it's physicalizing
that memory and feeling it and sensing
it and allowing it to come in
so try that you know if you feel like
you've been detached from emotion in
life it's time to allow that back in to
allow yourself to feel passionate and
excited about things again to allow
yourself to get dorked out about a new
learning opportunity a new thing you're
gonna see to allow yourself to say you
know what i did that good for me to have
a sense of pride about some things you
know you deserve that you did some good
things and it's also allowing yourself
not to be detached from negative things
you know so many people are so scared to
experience a negative thing that
it's like they've never developed any
strength or capability of dealing with
those things right do you know anybody
who can't handle conflict they're always
running from conflict because they've
always detached from that emotion oh i'm
scared i'm scared
part of the way that we become mature
and enlightened adults is we start to
face the things that we are fearful of
or we are scared of and we allow
ourselves to feel it and to sense it
it's okay to feel the fear it's okay to
feel uncomfortable about something it's
okay to feel vulnerable it's okay to
feel what other people might call
negative or scary or uncertain emotions
because the more comfort that you start
to have with uncomfortable emotions the
more comfort you have with uncomfortable
situations the more you start to develop
more consciousness about how to deal
with them right and the only way you're
going to develop comfort with them is
allowing yourself to accept that and to
acknowledge wow this is the feeling i'm
having right now about this why am i
feeling this way is this how i want to
feel will this add or contribute here is
there anything i can do to shift or
generate a new emotion that would be
more positive or healthy for me that's
consciousness so you have to be you
don't have to you can't do that if
you're detached from every emotion or
every opportunity and every experience
that comes into your life you have to
feel again habit number eight be happy
with richard davidson this is a quote
from william james he said the faculty
of voluntarily bringing back
a wandering attention over and over
again
is the very root of judgment
character
and will an education which should
improve this faculty would be the
education
par excellence
and then he went on to say but it is
easier to define this ideal
than to give practical directions for
bringing it about
i think if william james had
more
intimate familiarity with the
contemplative traditions he would have
instantaneously seen that these were
methods that can be used to educate
attention
a recent study published in a major
scientific journal used smartphones
to sample people's experience in the
world and they asked people several
questions they asked them what are you
doing right now
and i had to check off on a list of
activities and the second question is
where is your mind right now
is it focused on what you're doing or is
it focused elsewhere and the third
question that they ask them is how happy
are you or unhappy are you right at this
moment
and what was found in this study this
was a sample of thousands of people
what was found is that the average
american adult
spends 47 percent of her or his waking
life not paying attention to what
they're doing
folks we could do better
even if it's just the smidgen better
we could do better
and when they were not paying attention
to what they're doing
they reported that they were unhappy
so let me end
with just telling a little story
i was in dharmsala with his holiness the
dalai lama
on one occasion and
during a tea break
i was with him with just one other
person so just the three of us and there
was this the person who was with me was
this really crazy japanese scientist
and the japanese scientist leans over
and he said to his holiness your
holiness can you please tell us the time
in your life when you are the most happy
and i thought that was real that's a
really interesting question and just
like that his holiness said right now
habit number nine create new habits with
shauna shapiro our repeated experiences
shape our brain
does this remind you of anything right
it's exactly what this monk told me what
we practice becomes stronger
everything that we practice every single
moment matters
so these are brains from harvard i think
that makes them a little more special
and basically sarah lazar did this
wonderful early research and what she
found is that
meditators
the actual parts of their brain that
have to do with attention concentration
emotional intelligence compassion those
parts of the brain actually get stronger
bigger it's what it's called cortical
thickening
and that this thickening is correlated
with practice
what we practice gets stronger
so the way i like to think of it is we
have these super highways of habits
and they're just like they're well
grooved pathways in our brain right they
just
you know they're what we automatically
do
and what mindfulness is helping us start
to do is to kind of like
build kind of like i think of it as like
digging a country road you're you're
clearing all the brambles in your brain
you're creating this new neural pathway
that's like oh i'm gonna actually do it
with compassion this time or with a
little more patience or a little more
presence and so instead of going down
that same super highway of habit
we're
shifting and we're going down a
different pathway
and every single time that we do this
we're strengthening that pathway so that
eventually that pathway becomes the
habit and habit number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips
is concentrate with dandapani people
talk about being present being in the
moment being in the now and you see all
these cute little instagram quotes
floating around be in the moment be in
the now no one tells you how the hell to
do it right you can't be in the moment
if you can't concentrate
the ability to be present
stems from being able to be concentrated
and put your awareness on something or
someone
for a certain period of time exactly
yeah so how can i be in the moment here
with you if i can't concentrate so
everybody talks about the end product
which is be in the moment be present be
mindful mindfulness right being sold
like
you know bottled water everywhere
but they don't teach you concentration
you can't be mindful unless you
concentrate
mindfulness is a byproduct of
concentration in understanding the mind
the simple way i teach people is is
there's two things you need to
understand you need to understand is the
mind and there's awareness so let's
define both of them i define the mind as
a vast space with many different areas
within it one area of the mind is anger
one air is jealousy one there is
happiness food sex photography so many
different areas of the mind and then you
have awareness i define awareness as the
glowing ball of light so imagine an orb
or a ball of light that can float around
so
your mind doesn't move but it's the
awareness that travels to different
areas of the mind so you hear people say
all the time i have a monkey mind or my
mind travels a lot my mind's all over
the place technically i believe from my
experience that's false the mind doesn't
move but it's awareness that's traveling
within the mind so your awareness can go
to the happy area of the mind it can go
to the sad area of the mind it can go to
the scientific area of the mind your
goal is to control your awareness that
ball of light and determine where it
goes in your mind
and your ability to keep that awareness
in one area of the mind for an extended
period of time
is your ability to concentrate so if
you're reflecting on something you're
meditating on something it's your
awareness it's in one area of the mind
and you're holding it there long enough
to actually gain knowledge from it i
know you talk about reading just now
right someone opens a book is reading
the ability to keep the awareness on
that page
the ball of light on that page right
allows them to gain information
from the book but if they can't keep it
there long enough
they don't gain anything
right so understanding awareness and the
mind is the precursor to learning how to
concentrate i would say the simplest
thing you can do is practice doing one
thing at a time which is very difficult
for people
so if you're speaking with someone give
that person your undivided attention
keep your awareness on them so imagine
your awareness again as a ball of light
i'm speaking to jim my awareness drift
away i bring it back it drips away i
bring it back so i use gym as an
opportunity to practice concentrating so
if you have a spouse or partner or loved
one that you see every day or you speak
to every day then use that person as an
opportunity to practice concentration
every time you speak with your spouse
could be two hours throughout the day
give your spouse your undivided
attention now you have two hours of
practice then concentration now i've got
a special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through that's what the science says and
that is not good enough believe nation
we need to do better when you actually
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do this week you have a 91 chance of
following through and when you publicly
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment below on this video it jumps
even higher so i want that for you i
want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week so i can
celebrate with you
the most amazing thing
in your life
for most people in the normal
state of consciousness
and normal means
somewhat
or very insane
in the normal state of consciousness the
present moment is usually overlooked
habitually
unconsciously
people have been conditioned
to overlook
the most important thing
there ever is
[Music]
because your entire life
consists of
the present moment
there never has been
anything else everything happened in the
present moment and when you remember it
it's the present moment
and when you think about the future
which of course never arrives as the
future
it can only arrive as the present moment
but people live as if the present moment
were
undesirable
or an obstacle or they actively dislike
it
and some people habitually live actively
disliking the is-ness of the present
moment usually when you talk about the
now then people
it's usually associated with
okay
the first thing that
appears then in your awareness perhaps
is
your surroundings
and that's already a great step
into the now it's the first important
step into the now
to become aware
of whatever surrounds you the space that
surrounds you wherever you may be and
whatever
takes place in that space
and you may notice when you become aware
of those sense perceptions because it's
through sense perceptions that you
become aware of whatever
happens around you
that involves visual auditory and such
to some extent the other senses too
the main ones being
visual and
seeing and hearing
so as we enter the now we become more
aware of our
surroundings it's the first
step into the now
and now when you do that and let's do
that now just not as not thinking i'm
going to practice now not just becoming
more aware of your surroundings no
practice
and it's not a doing it's just
it's
an awareness arises of
this room
the people in this room the man sitting
on the chair talking the
beautiful arrangement there
and that is
the space of now so you can so what the
word to use is you acknowledge what is
and close to acknowledging you go a
little bit deeper
you appreciate
what is
what before
you probably overlooked completely
and
that's already a wonderful thing and
there are some people
who are not yet ready to go any deeper
than that and that's fine it's enough to
just go two steps into the now well
let's let's call it three people like
the idea of steps
let's call it step one you become more
aware of your surroundings
step two
you acknowledge
ah
and with the acknowledgement comes a
sense of the goodness of the ways in
which life manifests continuously around
you there is an aliveness in everything
even in the middle of a city you might
say oh i prefer the forest or the beach
or the mountains
but even in the middle of the city
whatever happens all the movements in
the middle of a city
are manifestations of life life
manifesting as human beings running
around as cars as houses buildings and
noise and so on and there's also
something there that is fine
it's your
an acknowledgement of
life
and then comes an appreciation oh
you you might see something that you
before had not appreciated the sky for
example
how many times are you aware of the sky
and say oh
and it's beautiful
and even a cloudy sky there's always
this light filtering through the clouds
now you might notice when you become
aware of the what i call the surface of
now which are the sensory perceptions
that reveal the world to you
[Music]
already a shift in consciousness happens
because now
you're not thinking as much
you cannot be very much aware of sense
perception and really be looking at the
sky or at a tree or a flower or a street
scene
and be thinking a lot you have to be
really there as the presence
for example now
so you simply acknowledge
the totality of this room
and that's beautiful
and then
you go a little deeper still
the next step
takes you deeper then you can ask
yourself
what else is there to them now apart
from the things that arise in my sense
perception what else is there say
anything else is that what the now is
what appears in the now
no
it's what appears in the now but it's
not yet to the now
so to become aware of the present moment
to become aware of sense perceptions is
an important step and some people are so
out of touch with their surroundings
they are never
where they are they are in their
the stream of their thinking as you
become more aware of your sense
perceptions
your alertness and when i say alertness
don't let that be just a conceptual
thing alertness needs to be something
that you can only can only know what
alert awareness is by experiencing alert
awareness you cannot understand
conceptually what alert awareness is
and everybody here
i would say
can
knows already and can verify in their
own experience
the difference between
being absorbed in your the inner being
identified with the voice in your head
which is habitual compulsive thinking
and
being in a state of alert awareness
[Music]
if you want seven more ways to be
mindful and present check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there being present is literally
nothing more than the skill of having
your thoughts be in this moment not in
the past not in the future but right
here observe where you are bring your
full senses